[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour un combat doit
qui s'annonce exceptionnel ce soir 9 ans
jean-paul absolument civ nos deux
combattants à l'eau dans la fange
sevré de côté lire stéphane qui a quand
même été trois fois champion du monde de
combat tous
il a gagné ses trois derniers matchs
très bâtiment les lui dans le méchant
vizir et de l'autre michel redoutable
car il a été six fois vainqueur du titre
international de chifoumi avec une
finale mémorable l'année dernière il a
gagné par pierre entre si l'on a mais ce
soir c'est le grand soir carey vont
s'affronter en free fight tous les coups
sont permis
et c'est parti le match commence
première dame et épanouie mais un coup
de doigt
ça commence fort michel aurait dû
protéger son doigt avec son doigt mais
il se redresse très bons jeunes
cuticules un coupe ongles il doit s'en
mordre les lui même et s'éloigne il va
chercher mais qu'est-ce qui fait c'était
une feuille de papier un obscurantiste
fait mal à regarder
[Applaudissements]
on dirait que stéphane a un flash back
pain je sais que tu es le meilleur que
tu vas gagner ce combat
quand tu seras sur le ring je croiserai
les moi même
ce flashback mère redonner du courage
qu'il se redresse
[Musique]
merde
max de la part de cette inégal pause et
d'orientation gp12 moretti de bagnères
arrêtez de baver
je vais pas de but
[Musique]
k